et france4 boeuf délégué départemental
du modem et pierre gentier il est avocat
au barreau de paris
messieurs bonjour merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france affronte
quatreboeufs première question quelle
lecture faites-vous de cette
mobilisation qui dure depuis cet été
les autres confrères journalistes
lui même que c'est une mobilisation qui
est assez protéiforme il y a eu
effectivement une période qui était
uniquement center et finalement à
écouter ce que ce qui nous a été donné à
entendre j'ai l'impression qu'à présent
cela redevient un peu comme à l'époque
des gilet jaune des manifestations
sociales donc du même coup y devient
difficile si vous l'êtes vous apporter
une réponse d'ensemble
jeu je peux vous dire ce que je pense de
la question sanitaire pour ce qui est
des revendications sociales elles sont
régulières elles sont légitimes ce que
je pourrais en dire c'est que en tous
les cas elles peuvent s'exprimer et je
me réjouis qu'elle s'exprime
pacifiquement
il ya eu une période très violente on se
souvient des saccages de l'appeler
triomphe il y a eu ensuite des
manifestations à mobile sanitaires qui
ont été et c'est très heureux totalement
pacifique de partage d'ailleurs ça a
permis de se rendre compte que quand les
manifestants étaient pacifiques il n'y
avait pas non plus de débordements
policiers et puis on a l'impression que
cela ôte vient l'expression d'un
mécontentement social qui existe donc
des pays à toutes les époques qui est
souvent légitime mais qui n'a pas de
lien avec la situation sanitaire
gentillet alors on en sait un depuis
quelques jours maintenant que
potentiellement le pass annie terre peut
être maintenu jusqu'à l'année prochaine
jusqu'à l'été
2022 mais sans certitude sega vrai
l'attaqué de l'as dit cette annonce ne
risque-t-elle pas de et un nouveau
souffle à la mobilisation actuelle
écoutez moi je l'espère là ce que nous
la talent mais sa sainte itium à la
succession des à la succession des
mensonges gouvernementaux je veux dire
on peut parler du masque ou tout début
de la crise on peut parler de son vous
avez dit s'agissant de l'extension du
pas salutaire en mai encore je me
souviens on nous disait qu'il n'était
pas question de l'étendre aux activités
quotidiennes finalement ça a été étendu
olivier ferrand le 25 juillet devant la
représentation nationale à l'assemblée
nationale donc avec promis qu' il n'est
plus tôt avait dit qu'il n'était pas
question de prolonger se passe au delà
de la date indiquée dans la loi c'est à
dire le 15 novembre
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on voit on se
rend compte que ça va être prolongée
peut-être jusqu'à l'été en tout cas ça
donne la capacité au gouvernement de le
faire jusqu'à l'été je veux dire s'ils
voulaient c'est systématiquement le même
scénario terre que à chaque fois on
avance pas à pas c'est temporaire et
finalement ce qui était prévu comme
exceptionnel devenir permanent c'est
comme l'état d'urgence sanitaire l'état
d'urgence sanitaire ça fait un an et
demi qu'on est dedans on n'arrive pas à
en sortir et enfin dernière chose je
trouve que même sur le plan sanitaire ou
déjà moi je trouve que ce pass sanitaire
il ya beaucoup de choses à dire et je
vais personnellement opposé à se passe
mais en plus de ça regardez on parle
d'une reconduction au moment où la
situation non pas seulement nationale
mais européenne et mondiale
s'améliore ça veut dire que sur le plan
sanitaire la reconduction de ce pass est
doublement une absurdité ce mot -
france 80 c'est vrai que c'est une
question qui revient aussi la situation
épidémique s'améliore pourquoi alors on
le passe à l'inter va t'il être étendue
au moins jusque peut-être jusqu'à l'été
de l'année prochaine c'est vrai que
c'est une question qui revient souvent
à donner une
excuse vaud qui est que pendant la
période de la campagne présidentielle il
n'y a pas de cession et que donc
s'il y avait nécessité de mesures
sanitaires du parlement ne pourrait pas
légiférer à ce moment là donc le
gouvernement dit qu'il faudrait
peut-être
légiférer à titre préventif
les mes amis du modem et moi même sommes
assez rétif je dois le dire une
situation exceptionnelle où vous
souvenez qu'au printemps d'ailleurs il
ya vécu 45 députés modem qui avaient
voté contre un texte qui avait dû être
modifié par le gouvernement
je pense j'espère que des voix dans la
majorité
s'élèveront pour en tous les cas essayé
d'insister sur le fait que les mesures
qui sont prises doivent être limitées
dans le temps et proportionnée pour le
reste oui le gouvernement navigue à vue
je pense que tous les gouvernements
d'alic t'as vu et du côté des
manifestants je le dis sans aucune
commisération mais
les manifestants ont aussi tendance à na
li té un peu à vue c'est à dire que
d'ailleurs mans mon interlocuteur ap la
question des masques au fouillis il
voulait des masques quand il n'y en
avait pas quand il y en a une en voulait
plus ils voulaient du vaccin quand il
n'y en avait pas papier le vaccin il
n'en voulait plus donc si vous voulez
c'est un peu comme dans un divorce
quoique 18 une des parties l'autre sera
en désaccord donc bon voilà il faut un
peu de bonne foi comme lui dit françois
bayrou une météo stagiaires tour je
pense que là la vérité et le courage
c'est juste milieu et j'espère que le
gouvernement
adoptera éclairé par le parlement des
mesures les plus légère possible et les
plus provisoires possible pierre
gentillet il me semble que vous avez
quelque chose à dire oui effectivement
je peux pas trop attaqué au cutter mais
en fait à aucun moment on a dit enfin
que qu'on ne voulait pas du vaccin est
ce qu on dit simplement en fait le
principe il faut pas comprendre les gens
qui sont contre le pass et les gens qui
sont contre le principe du vaccin et les
gens qui sont contre le principe du
vaccin il est d'un quasiment une ultra
ultra minorité la majorité des gens dans
ce pays qu'est ce qu'ils disent distrait
simplement autres cas des gens qui
défilent et dis très simplement si vous
avez un problème si vous voulez vous
faire vacciner faites vous vacciner si
moi je ne peux pas me faire vacciner je
ne me fais pas vacciner ensuite on ne
dira vous faites circuler virus mais on
vous répète on vous répondra quel est le
problème dans la mesure où vous vous
êtes vacciné ou alors vous avez accès
aux vaccins vous voyez tout ça ça prouve
que imposé à derrière des restrictions
de liberté alors qu'il suffit simplement
de considérer la liberté individuelle et
la responsabilité individuelle de chacun
maintenant que je le rappelle nous avons
tous accès aux vaccins et nous pouvons
l'utiliser si nous le voulons je trouve
que dans ce contexte ces restrictions de
libertés sont totalement injustifié et
disproportionné
messieurs merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france france 4 bob vous
êtes délégué départemental du modem
merci à vous et puis pierre gentier
avocat au barreau de paris merci à vous
également